et on en parle avec le round
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir saison merci
d'être avec nous pour bien comprendre
soir projetant concrètement à la dame de
rangoon
alors la police aurait trouvé à son
ancien domicile à des talkie walkie
elle a retrouvé aussi à un brouilleur
démission et puis le procureur lui
reproche de ne pas avoir respecté toutes
les règles de confinement lors de la
campagne électorale de l'année dernière
du mois d'octobre dernier
et puis plus sérieusement on lui
reproche d'avoir détourné des fonds
publics pour construire une maison et
enfin on lui reproche une corruption
elle aurait touché 600 mille dollars et
11 kilos d'or à titre de d'un paiement
pour pour services rendus dans une
corruption
alors évidemment certains certains c'est
cette batterie de d'accusation est
destiné à éliminer
évidemment on s'en soucie du paysage
politique
c'est l'objectif de la junte qui veut
l'écarter tout à fait et effectivement
avec les deux dernières accusations qui
sont aggravés corruption et bien la
junte cherchent à ternir l'image de
l'icône images de du prix nobel de la
paix 91 et à dans le fond nuire à sa
notoriété à la fois au sein de l'opinion
publique birmane et à l'étranger il
n'est pas sûr que cela réussisse
en effet il semble bien que les
manifestations se poursuivent et que la
junte soit la seule à croire que ce
procès pourrait lui rapporter quelque
chose en terme politique où on est le
pays la birmanie aujourd'hui
alors sur le plan interne les choses
vont évidemment très mal puisque
l'économie est à l'arrêt il ya toujours
des manifestations
le système bancaire ne fonctionne plus
il y à une désobéissance civile
généralisée dans les écoles dans les
universités et on voit aussi un
phénomène inflationniste
le prix de l'essence augmenté de 25 %
depuis le 1er février c'est à dire
depuis le coup d'état et les produits
essentiels venant à manquer le
gouvernement les militaires ont dû lever
toutes les licences d'importation est
également toutes les taxes à
l'importation alors pour que les
produits de première nécessité aliments
médicaments puissent rentrer sur le
territoire birman donc la situation est
très mauvaise sur le plan international
ça ne va pas mieux puisque même la chine
qui soutient le régime birman s'inquiète
maintenant du fait que certaines usines
chinoises ont été attaqués par les
manifestants qui justement accusent la
chine de soutenir le régime et que ce
que veut surtout la chine
c'est que le calme revienne pour
continuer à faire des affaires en
birmanie et puis par ailleurs laser and
les pays d'asie du sud-est puisque la
birmanie est l'un des dix pays membres
l'association du sud est asiatique et
que le 24 avril dernier le général chef
de la junte avait accepté de se rendre à
un sommet à jakarta où il avait été un
peu sermonner mais finalement il avait
évité une condamnation en acceptant une
médiation en acceptant qu'il y ait un
médiateur de désigner cette médiation et
bien elle a été exercée en pure perte
par le secrétaire général de l'aser al
accompagné d'une mise à faire étrangères
de broussailles qui exerce actuellement
la présidence du conseil des mises à
faire d'étrangères delà des halles ils
ont été il ya quelques jours
en en birmanie ils ont vu les officiels
bien entendu ils n'ont pas eu accès à
l'opposition ni à marthon souci ni aux
autres opposants qui sont soit en prison
soit l'étranger et par conséquent cette
mission n'a pas à ce stade
servi à grand chose donc le régime et
est virtuellement isolé est en fait le
plus clair de résultats plus claire de
l'ouverture de ce procès c'est qu'on ne
compte pas les plus des généraux et de
la répression qui a fait 900 morts en
quatre mois
depuis quelques semaines les mêmes
depuis deux mois on n'en parlait plus
dans la presse occidentale et bien à
partir d'aujourd'hui on au repas
dernière question touche raison la junte
militaire est ce qu'elle parviendra à
ses fins elle vient aujourd'hui de se
tirer une balle dans le pied ce qui pour
des militaires est un peu un comble
parce que en effet il y à un certain
nombre de députés qui était élu à cette
assemblée qui a été donc 10 août à cette
assemblée élue avec grande majorité des
membres du parti devait l'amener tout ce
qui est certains de ses députés ont
formé un gouvernement en exil
ce gouvernement en exil est formé de
jeunes députés qui réfléchissent à
l'avenir et qui pensent que à l'avenir
il faut sans doute faire évoluer la
constitution birmane vers une
constitution fédérale
il faut par conséquent prendre langue
avec les minorités ethniques ce qu'ils
font une autre technique qui se sont
révoltés contre les généraux contre la
junte et prendre langue avec elle pour
des jeux voir dans quelle mesure il
pourrait y avoir un régime beaucoup plus
inclusif par la suite une fois que la
junte aura été obligé de passer la main
donc les généraux sont en train
d'éliminer madame aung san suu kyi du
champ politique alors que finalement il
avait les accommodements avec elle et
que l avait couvert leurs agissements
à propos des rohingya propos l'expulsion
les musulmans ringa et ils vont se
retrouver soi sans interlocuteur soit
avec des interlocuteurs beaucoup plus
difficile
ce gouvernement en exil qui cherche à
être reconnu sur le plan international
d'abord par les pays d'asie a ensuite
par les autres pays de la région
peut-être que la chine
moment donné l'un d'eux chercheront à
faire rebondir la la médiation de
l'asian pour ramener les militaires
birmans à la raison est arrivé à un
dialogue avec l'opposition
il débouche sur une solution
démocratique
merci toad blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales